and now the nominees were the best
political speech by an entertainment
celebrity Meryl Streep Jesse Williams
Ashley Judd that Sheriff from stranger
things the less attractive Zach
Galifianakis and the winner is less
attractive Zach Galifianakis thank you
thank you very much you know takes a lot
of courage to stand up and say things
that everyone in the room already wants
to hear and I think we entertainment
celebrities are going to be vilified for
our bravery here tonight but it's our
job to unify a country that has been
torn apart by hate and ignorance and
racism and misogyny and pickup trucks
and domestic beer and Waffle House's
stupid accent how did our country become
so divided it's time now for us to join
together as American and destroy the
other half of America that refuses to
believe in what we believe in we must
fight for peace and we must continue
fighting until mixed martial arts become
fine art till cracker-barrel become
sweet
maril kill fast and furious 8 becomes
Hamilton - thank you very much my lord
thank you
enemy's tactics Rita Lansky
[Music]